let's say that we are dealing with a
geometric series and there are some
things that we know about this geometric
series for example we know that the
first term of our geometric series is a
so that is our first first term we also
know the common ratio of our geometric
series and we're gonna call that R so
this is the common ratio and we also
know that it's a finite geometric series
so let me write this it is finite so
there's a finite number of terms and
let's say that n is equal to the number
of terms the number of terms and we're
gonna use a notation we're going to use
the notation S sub n to donate to denote
the sum the sum of first first of first
n terms and the goal of this whole video
is using this information coming up with
a general formula for the sum of the
first n terms to a formula for
evaluating a geometric series so let's
write out S sub n just just get a
feeling for what it would look like so S
sub n is going to be equal to where you
have your first term here which is an A
and then what's our second term going to
be
what's going to be this is a geometric
series so it's going to be a times the
common ratio so it's going to be the
first term times the common ratio so the
first term times R now what's the third
term going to be well it's going to be
the second term times our common ratio
again so it's going to be a R times R or
a R squared a R squared and we could go
all the way to our nth term so we're
going to go all the way to the nth term
and you might be tempted to say it's
going to be a times R to the nth power
but we have to be careful here because
notice our first term is really a r to
the 0th power second term is a R to the
first power our third term is a R to the
second power so whatever term we're on
the exponent is that
that term number minus one so if we're
on the nth term it's going to be a R to
the N minus ones power so we want to
come up with a nice clean formula for
evaluating this and we're gonna instance
we're gonna use a little trick to do it
to do it we're gonna think about what R
times the sum is and we're going to
subtract that out so we're gonna take
the R times that some R times times the
sum of the first n terms actually let's
just multiply negative R negative R
times it's something that we can just
add these two things and you'll see that
it cleans this thing up nicely so what
is this going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to well if you
multiply if we multiply a times negative
R we will get we will get negative a R
and I'm just gonna write it right
underneath this one so if you multiply
this times negative R I'm just gonna
multiply every one of these terms by
negative R that's equivalent of
multiplying negative R times the sum I'm
distributing the negative R so if I
multiply it times this term a times
negative R that's going to be negative
that's going to be negative a R and if I
multiply a R times negative R that's
going to be negative a R squared
negative a r squared you might see where
this is going
and just to be clear what's what's going
on that's that term times negative R
times negative R this is that term times
negative R and we would keep going all
the way to the the term the term this
the term before this times negative R so
if I the term before this times negative
R is going to be a is going to be
negative so you let me put subtraction
signs it's going to be negative a times
times R to the n minus 1 power R to the
n minus 1 power that was a term right
before this that was a times R to the n
minus 2 times negative R is going to
give us this so it's gonna get us right
over there and then finally we take this
last
term and you multiply it by negative R
what do you get you get negative a
negative a and then times R to the N R
to the N you multiply this times the
negative U at the negative a and then R
to the N minus one times R or times R to
the first well this is going to be R to
the N and now what's interesting here is
this we can add up the left side and we
can add up the right hand side so let's
do that so let's do that
on the left hand side we get S sub n
minus R minus R times S sub n S sub N
and on the right hand side we have
something very cool happening notice
it's a we still have that the a sits
there but everything else except for
this last thing is going to is going to
cancel out so these two are gonna cancel
out these two are gonna cancel out let
me do that a little neater these two are
gonna cancel out these two are going to
be cancel out and all we're gonna have
left with is a negative a R to the end
so it's going to be a minus a times R to
the nth power and now we can just solve
for S sub N and we have our formula what
we were looking for so let's see we can
factor out an S sub n on the left hand
side so you get an S sub n the sum of
our first n terms you factor that out so
it's going to be x times 1 minus R is
going to be equal to and on the right
hand side we can actually factor out an
a so it's going to be a times 1 minus R
to the N and so to solve for S sub n the
sum of our first n terms we deserve a
little bit of a drumroll here S sub n is
going to be equal to this divided by 1
minus R so it's going to be a times 1
minus R to the N over 1 minus R and
we're done we have figured out our our
formula for the sum or for the sum of a
finite for a finite
geometric series and so in the next few
videos or in future videos we will apply
this and I encourage you whenever you
whenever you use this formula it's very
important now that you know where it
came from that you really keep close
track of how many terms you are actually
summing up sometimes you might have a
Sigma T Sigma notation it starts it
might start its index at zero and then
goes up to a number in which case you're
gonna have that number plus one term so
you have to be very careful this is the
number of terms this is the first term
here we define it up here and is the
number of terms the first n terms are is
our common ratio